tout a commencé ce mercredi avec un
projet de loi que le gouvernement
britannique a présenté au parlement un
projet de loi qui contredit en partie
l'accord déjà signé encadrant la sortie
du royaume uni de l'union européenne
pour faire simple ce texte donnera à
londres le pouvoir de prendre
unilatéralement des décisions
commerciales dans sa province d'irlande
du nord des pouvoirs censé pourtant être
partagées avec les européens
selon l'accord conclu l'an dernier une
manoeuvre violent le droit international
du propre aveu de boris johnson mais
justifiée face à la menace de l'ue et
d'instaurer un blocus alimentaire en
irlande du nord
faux lui a répondu de son côté la
ministre irlandaise de la justice
je dois dire que nous n'avons jamais
sérieusement cru que le lieu serait
capable d'utiliser un traité négocié de
bonne foi pour instaurer un blocus sur
une partie du royaume uni ou qu'ils
menaceraient réellement de détruire
l'intégrité économique et territoriale
du royaume uni toute insinuation selon
laquelle cela va créer une nouvelle
frontière est tout simplement fausse le
traité gars entier également les
l'intégrité de l'irlande du nord en tant
que partie intégrante du royaume uni
face à cette escalade de tensions entre
eux ex partenaires européens
charles michel s'est entretenu dimanche
par téléphone avec le premier ministre
irlandais michael martin le président du
conseil européen
exhorte londres à appliquer complètement
l'accord de sortie de l'ue appelle avec
michael martin
l'accord de retrait doit être pleinement
mises en oeuvre doit assurer la paix et
la stabilité en irlande et préserver
l'intégrité du marché unique
il est temps pour le gouvernement
britannique de prendre ses
responsabilités la crédibilité
internationale de la signature du
royaume uni est en jeu pour autant le
gouvernement britannique ne semble pas
enclin à céder après avoir rejeté jeudi
l'ultimatum de bruxelles lui intimant de
retirer son projet de loi avant fin
septembre sous peine de poursuites
judiciaires
boris johnson souhaite entamer dès ce
lundi l'examen de son projet à la
chambre des communes où il dispose d'une
majorité de 81 sièges